hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien de même général de gaulle at-il
serré dans la foule qui tout au long de
son voyage en franche-comté l'acclamer
avec chaleur en effet à dole à lons le
saunier partout s'arrêta le cortège
présidentiel
une foule compacte se pressait autour du
général pour le voir et l'écouter
on sait qu'au cours de ce voyage un
projet d'attentât devait être découverts
et leurs promoteurs arrêter cet incident
ne changea rien au déroulement des
cérémonies à l'horaire du voyage et
n'enthousiasme général non manifesta que
plus d'ampleur
[Musique]
dans ses nombreuses allocutions le
général de gaulle a évoqué les épreuves
surmontées et dont la plus récente est
le drame algérien les il a surtout parlé
de l'europe de demain cette europe qui
doit être l'europe des peuples c'est à
dire celle des états et non pas celle
des monts des mythes et des combinaisons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours entre berlin est et
berlin ouest des messages s'échange
messages lumineux que la lumière du jour
en plus discret aussi le gouvernement de
planck off sans doute la satisfait de la
barrière qui l'adresser s'est mis en
devoir de renforcer et d'étendre ce
barrage constamment surveillé que les
allemands de l'ouest nomme le mur de la
honte
[Musique]
les nouveaux travaux comporteront des
bars donné dix mètres de terre labourée
30 m de terrains nus des barbelés un
champ de mines de 25 mètres des barbelés
130 m de terrain où toute végétation et
toute construction auront été supprimés
une zone de cinq km où l'on ne pourra
accéder qu'avec un sauf-conduit spécial
l'image d'un immense camp de
concentration
[Musique]
la faire la sienne est elle enfin réglé
le prince bonhomme est venu dans la
plaine des jarres donné son accord à la
constitution d'un gouvernement d'union
nationale auquel d'ailleurs il ne
participera pas
le prince où va nous vendre lui chef du
pathet lao d'obédience communiste sera
ministre de l'économie et du plan le
général phung me pro occidental sera
ministre des finances quant au rôle de
premier ministre il sera assumé par le
prince neutraliste souvent à foum a
chargé également de la défense nationale
de l'action sociale et des anciens
combattants après cinquante crise les
princes laotien sont enfin d'accord la
satisfaction est semble-t-il général
dans le monde
[Musique]
on
hong kong n'a pas résolu ses problèmes
il s'en faut la ville surpeuplée
incapables de loger tous ces immigrants
elle compte actuellement trois millions
et demi d'habitants se trouve maintenant
devant le problème de l'eau hong kong a
soif une sécheresse exceptionnelle à
vider les torrents où ne coule plus
qu'un mince filet d'eau
bien sûr on construit un nouveau
réservoir mais les travaux sont encore
loin d'être achevé et le pipeline qui le
reliera la ville n'est pas installé
pour l'heure le saut est roi et la
corvée d'eau occupe l'essentiel des
activités des femmes et des enfants hong
kong se débattait déjà avec le problème
du logement de la nourriture et du
travail d'une population pléthorique 116
grossi par les réfugiés chinois le
manque d'eau vient encore de compliquer
dramatiquement la situation
[Musique]
le soleil on l'a attendu longtemps mais
il ya cette année du nouveau sous le
soleil un style tout neuf le style petit
matelot a pris l'offensive bad pantalon
largement évasée tricot rayé volontiers
barré d'un ceinturon qui fait la taille
basse la nouvelle vague n'aura pas que
le pied ma les robes elles sont rares ce
portrait liés à la matelote mais on leur
préfère les pantalons et les mariniers
et le poupon est toujours bien
les plages donc ainsi voir fleurir toute
une armée de petits marins joly il faut
lire à troquer
en attendant les bords de mer la
nouvelle mode s'est affirmée sur les
bords de marne ce qui a permis de
constater que les maillots de bain avait
aussi résolument évolué
[Musique]
des deux pièces mais le soutien gorge
peut devenir brassière et le slip
culotte
les maillots une pièce on leur devant -
dégager le décolleté se portent
véritablement dans le dos avec alors la
plus grande générosité mais avec
l'addition d'un noeud pour les plus
collet monté grande veuves aussi des
maillots asymétrique il reste qu'il y
aura toujours bien entendu des
réactionnaires
[Musique]
ces nouveaux modèles ne sont pas
allergiques à l'eau
[Musique]
le nom
l'hôtel de ville après l'hôpital
mustapha
l'offensive de destruction avait marqué
une nette recrudescence à alger et
l'explosion de 50 kg de plastique dans
la maison communale avait fait un mort
et 43 blessés parmi les war qui était
cantonné
m
mais cette dévastation spectaculaire
aura-t-elle marquer la fin de
l'opération terre brûlée le 17 juin qui
vit la conclusion des accords fnl nous
as or at il marqué en algérie la fin du
drame on veut le croire et ils voudront
sans aucun doute le croire ce que deux
jours plus tôt la peur avait jeté vers
le port d'alger la peur peur du meurtre
lors d'un enlèvement peur d'une balle
perdue peur de tout
ils étaient ce jour-là 15 cents ou 2000
femmes enfants vieillards qui s'embarque
est pour la métropole sur l'un des
bateaux qui font sans interruption la
navette à travers la méditerranée
92000 rapatriés en 12 jours elle avait
été le record des départs depuis le
discours de monsieur benbada à tunis en
25 heures de traversée sur le pont du
navire ils ont essayé d'oublier le
cauchemar dans lequel il vivait et
beaucoup pensaient que sans doute il
était parti pour ne plus revenir
ils sont arrivés soulager peut être mais
surtout désorienté genre de condition
modeste vieillard qui avait vécu en
algérie toute leur vie ils ont tout
laissé de l'autre côté de la mer à cela
la corde rocher noir apporte-t-il la
promesse d'un apaisement de nos
possibilités de retour la promesse que
les enfants accueillis à la pouponnière
n'auront pas commencer à marseille une
vie de déracinés et pour tous en france
comme en algérie l'heure qui vient de
sonner est-elle le signe de la
réconciliation
de l'espoir retrouvé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]